- All right, let's finish
up with something super fun
I found scrolling through social media.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
So sure, a charity can
straight up ask for money
to go to a good cause.
That's awesome.
But one Minnesota organization
has gotten super creative
with their fundraising.
Every year they host a bed race.
That's right.
Hundreds of teams dress up in costumes
and ride mattresses down the tubing hill.
I love these people.
In the past 25 years, the
event has helped raise
more than 1 million to
provide those in need
with quality furniture
and household goods.
Super cool.
We have the executive director
of Bridging on the line
watching on KSTP in Minneapolis.
Let's say hi to Mark, everybody.
(audience cheering)
- Hi Kelly.
- What's up, man?
So tell us about this annual bed race.
How crazy does it get?
Do people get crazy there?
- It gets super crazy.
The annual Original Mattress
Factory Bed Race for Bridging
is a fabulous event.
So, people gather in teams of four,
they hop on a covered queen
size mattress in costume
like an inflatable unicorn
and then they raced down
a local snow tubing hill.
One year we had a team dressed as babies.
They literally wore a sheet as a diaper.
We hope to have 100 teams
this year racing with us.
Ages will be 18 all the way up
to sometimes in their mid-seventies
people choose to join us
in this important cause.
And those beds that we race on, well,
we give those to the families
whom we're privileged to serve
after the event.
So it is our 25th year.
It is on Saturday, March 11th,
and we hope to raise $125,000
to support our important cause.
- Oh, that's incredible.
Well, tell us more about Bridging.
- Yeah. We're a nonprofit furniture bank
and we get to work with
people who are transitioning
out of homelessness into stable housing,
and we get to provide them
with all the furniture
and household goods that are
gonna go into their new home.
In fact, they get to select those items
at one of our two locations.
So they get to pick out their beds,
their kitchen tables and chairs,
their upholstered furniture.
They get to pick out their dishes,
their linens, their lamps,
all those things that are in our home
that we so often take for
granted they don't have.
And we get to provide that
for those amazing people.
In fact, we celebrate in
our 36 years of existence
that we have been able to serve
more than 110,000 households
in our Twin Cities community.
We like to say we furnish homes with hope.
- Ah, that's so, that's incredible, man.
Thank you so much, Mark.
I'm loving your post right now, all right.
And that's not all.
- I really appreciate that Kelly.
Thanks so much.
- Oh, that, well, no, we're not done.
That's not all.
Our season long partner
Pilot Pen makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to honor truly unstoppable people,
just like the people in the race
and people like you who serve,
so they're gonna be writing
Bridging a check for $1,000.
How's that sound?
- Hey, thank you so much.
That is awesome.
We're on our way to $125,000 goal.
Thank you, thank you.
- Aw, awesome.
Thank you so much, mark.
And thank you to all our guests this hour,
Rose Byrne, Harry Hamlin, Rochelle,
Sean Adam, Lucas Graham, and Micky Guidan.
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, try and change it.